VERY STORY TONIGHT.
OKAY?
THERE IS MORE.
THIS IS HAPPENING AS THIS DAY
MARKS NINE MONTHS, CAN YOU
BELIEVE IT'S BEEN NINE MONTHS
SINCE ONE OF THE WORST ATTACKS
IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
THAT WAS THE DAY THAT BLOOD
THIRSTY TRUMP SUPPORTING RIOTERS
ATTACKED THE UNITED STATES
CAPITOL, THE CAPITOL OF THE
UNITED STATES.
STORMING THE BUILDING ALL CAUGHT
ON LIVE TELEVISION BEATING
POLICE TRYING TO DEFEND THE
CAPITOL WITHIN AN INCH OF THEIR
LIVES AND HUNTING LAWMAKERS WHO
WERE FORCED TO FLEE.
NINE MONTHS SINCE WE WATCHED ALL
OF THAT IN HORROR.
WATCHED AS IT WAS HAPPENING.
NOW THE CLOCK IS TICKING FOR
SEVERAL TOP AIDS AND ADVISORS TO
FORMER PRESIDENT, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT TO TURNOVER DOCUMENTS
TO THE SELECT COMMITTEE
INVESTIGATING WHAT HAPPENED NINE
MONTHS AGO AND SOURCES SAY THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO PHYSICALLY
SERVE THE SUBPOENA TO ONE OF
THOSE AIDES AND THAT'S DAN, THE
COMMUNICATIONS GUY.
THEY WANT TO FIND OUT WHAT HE
KNOWS ABOUT VIDEOS LIKE THIS
ONE.
>> GO HOME.
WE LOVE YOU.
YOU'RE VERY SPECIAL.
YOU'VE SEEN WHAT HAPPENS.
YOU SEE THE WAY OTHERS ARE
TREATED THAT ARE SO BAD AND SO
EVIL.
I KNOW HOW YOU FEEL.
>> MEANWHILE, THE DISGRACED
TWICE IMPEACHED ONE TERM EX
PRESIDENT IS SHOWING THAT YOU
JUST -- WHY HE IS DISGRACED
PUTTING OUT A STATEMENT ACTUALLY
IT'S NOTHING BUT A RANT, REALLY
CLAIMING THE REAL ENSURE
RECOLLECTION HAPPENED ON
NOVEMBER 3rd, THE DAY JOE BIDEN
WON THE PRESIDENCY WITH MORE
THAN 81 MILLION VOTES.
MORE VOTES THAN THE FORMER GUY.
THAT WAS THE DAY THE EX
PRESIDENT LOST.
IT'S JUST ANOTHER RANT/STATEMENT
HE'S BEEN PUTTING OUT SINCE HE
WAS KICKED OFF TWITTER ON
JANUARY 6th BECAUSE THEY FEARED
THAT HE WOULD INCITE MORE
VIOLENCE AND HE IS STILL PUSHING
THE BIG LIE.
THE LIE THAT EXPLODED INTO
VIOLENCE AT THE CAPITOL AND HERE
IS THE THING ABOUT PUSHING
LYING.
WHEN YOU LIE TO PEOPLE OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AND OVER, WHEN YOU
TELL THEM THEIR GOVERNMENT IS
LYING TO THEM, THEY WON'T
BELIEVE YOU EVEN WHEN YOU'RE
TRYING TO SAVE THEIR LIVES.
OKAY?
THAT IS WHY THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES, THAT IS WHY HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES IS PUTTING OUT A
SERIES OF NEW ADS AIMED AT
CONVINING PEOPLE STILL VACCINE
HESITANT, ADS THAT DON'T
SUGARCOAT WHAT IT'S LIKE TO HAVE
AND ALMOST DIE FROM COVID.
>> BEEN IN THE HOSPITAL FOR 7
SIX DAYS NOW AND BY THE GRACE OF
GOD, I'M STILL HERE.
IT WAS A LOT OF DARK TIMES THEN.
I DIED THREE TIMES.
THEY GAVE ME A 5% CHANCE AT
LIVING.
SO I HIGHLY RECOMMEND EVERYBODY
TO GET THE VACCINES AND REALLY
PROTECT THEMSEVES BECAUSE THIS
IS NO JOKE.
>> NO JOKE.
NO JOKE.
THAT'S THE BRUTAL TRUTH FOR
THOSE WHO GET COVID.
THIS COUNTRY IS AVERAGING
133,000 CASES A DAY.
THE VAST MAJORITY UNVACCINATED
PEOPLE.
BUT LISTEN TO WHAT HAPPENED.
OKAY?
PAY ATTENTION.
HAVE A SEAT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TIME -- IF
YOU'RE HAVING A COCKTAIL,
WHATEVER IT IS GETTING READY FOR
BET.
HAVE A SEAT, PAY ATTENTION TO
THIS.
LINDSEY GRAHAM TRIED TO CONVINCE
PEOPLE TO THINK ABOUT, JUST TO
THINK ABOUT GETTING VACCINATED.
HERE IT IS.
>> SO THE BOTTOM LINE IS I TOOK
THE VACCINE.
I'VE HAD IT.
IT KICKS YOUR BUTT.
IF YOU HAVEN'T HAD THE VACCINE,
YOU OUGHT TO THINK ABOUT GETTING
IT --
>> NO!
>> I DON'T TELL YOU TO GET IT.
YOU OUGHT TO THINK ABOUT IT.
>> NO!
>> I'M GLAD I GOT IT.
92% OF THE PEOPLE IN THE
HOSPITALS IN SOUTH CAROLINA ARE
UNVACCINATED.
>> OH MY GOD.
>> LIES.
>> I'M WITH YOU ON --
>> LORD JESUS.
>> I'M WITH YOU THAT IT'S
PROBABLY UNOUNCE
CONSTITUTIONAL --
>> GOD HELP ME.
>> SHE'S RIGHT.
LORD HELP ME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
LORD HELP ME.
IS IT ANY WONDER WHY FAR TOO
MANY PEOPLE DON'T TRUST VACCINES
WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN FED A STEADY
DIET OF LIES AND MISINFORMATION
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING?
>> NO.
NOT GETTING THAT VACCINE.
NO, NO, NO, NO.
THEM VACCINES ARE NOT GOOD HUN.
>> ARE YOU VACCINATED?
>> NO, BUT I HAVE A LOT OF
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE AT MY HOUSE.
>> HAVE YOU GOT YOUR VACCINE
SHOT?
>> NO.
>> WHY?
>> THEY HAVEN'T TESTED IT ENOUGH
FROM MY OPINION.
>> I DON'T TRUST THE GOVERNMENT.
I DON'T TRUST THE CDC, I DON'T
TRUST NONE OF THEM.
>> DO YOU KNOW ANY PEOPLE THAT
GOT SICK OR DIED?
>> I KNOW THREE PEOPLE THAT GOT
IT AND DIED BUT I KNOW PEOPLE
THAT GOT CANCER AND DIED, TOO.
>> YOU KNOW THREE PEOPLE THAT
DIED FROM CORONAVIRUS AND YOU
WON'T GET THE VACCINE?
>> NO, I LIKE I SAID, I DON'T
NEED THE VACCINE.
>> HAVE YOU GUYS GOTTEN
VACCINATED?
>> NO, WON'T DO IT.
>> WHY?
>> I'M ALLERGIC TO A LOT OF THE
THINGS IN THE CHEMICALS AND
STUFF LIKE THAT AND FREEDOM.
YOU GET TO CHOOSE.
IF YOU CAN HAVE AN ABORTION AND
CHOOSE YOUR BODY, I SHOULD BE
ABLE TO CHOOSE IF I GET A SHOT.
>> I KNOW.
I KNOW.
LOOK, THEY'VE BEEN FED THIS
STEADY DIET OF MISINFORMATION,
SO THERE IS THAT.
HOWEVER, THEY ARE ADULTS.
LET'S REMEMBER THAT WHERE THOSE
LIES AND MISINFORMATION CAME
FROM.
>> I SAID SUPPOSING YOU BROUGHT
THE LIGHT INSIDE THE BODY, WHICH
YOU CAN DO THROUGH THE SKIN OR
IN SOME OTHER WAY AND I THINK
YOU SAID YOU'RE GOING TO TEST
THAT, TOO.
SOUNDS INTERESTING.
AND THEN I SEE THE DISINFECTANT
KNOCKS IT OUT IN A MINUTE BY
INJECTION INSIDE OR A CLEANING.
IT GETS IN THE LUNGS.
>> SO, YOU KNOW, WE LIVE THROUGH
THAT.
HARD TO BELIEVE, RIGHT?
YOU KNOW, SOMETIMES I FEEL BAD
BECAUSE I LAUGHED ABOUT IT BUT
IT'S NOT FUNNY.
I MEAN, IT'S LAUGHABLE.
IT'S RIDICULOUS TO THINK THAT.
THAT IS -- THAT WAS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AT THE TIME TALKING ABOUT A
DEADLY PANDEMIC AND LIGHT INSIDE
THE BODY OF BLEACH AND ALL OF
THAT.
THAT'S WHERE THAT CAME FROM.
AND THEN IF THEY DIDN'T SEE
THE -- HOW LUDICROUS THAT WAS,
WHY WOULD THEY DO IT NOW?
RIGHT.
SAME THING WITH THE POLLS.
WE LOVE TRUMP.
PEOPLE ROMANTICIZE HISTORY.
THEY MOVE ON.
THINGS DON'T SEEM BAD IN THE
REARVIEW MIRROR.
JANUARY 6th WASN'T THAT BAD AND
THE PANDEMIC WASN'T BAD.
IT WAS AWFUL.
ALL OF IT.
THAT'S WHERE ALL OF THAT B.S.
CAME FROM.
THAT GUY.
BUT NOW HE'S NO LONGER IN POWER
SO IT IS THE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
POWER NOW STILL MAKING EXCUSES
FOR HIM BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
HANG ON TO POWER, NOT THAT THEY
WANT TO EDUCATE PEOPLE OR DO
WHAT'S RIGHT FOR PEOPLE OR SAVE
THEIR LIVES, THEY JUST WANT TO
HANG ON TO POWER AND THEY THINK
THAT'S THE BEST WAY TO DO IT
BECAUSE PEOPLE'S IGNORANCE --
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN EXPLOITED FOR
THEIR LACK OF KNOWLEDGE.
LET'S PUT IT THAT WAY AND
BECAUSE PEOPLE WANT TO HAVE
THEIR BELIEVES CONFIRMED AND
RECONFIRMED AND RECONFIRMED.
HOW COULD HE BE WRONG?
WE VOTED FOR HIM.
HE LIED TO YOU.PANDEMIC.
LIES RUNNING ON FACEBOOK AND THE
BIG LIE THAT FUELED THAT VIOLENT
ATTACK ON OUR NATION'S CAPITOL
NINE MONTHS AGO.
I HAVE SAID IT BEFORE, LIES AND
MISINFORMATION.
THEY ARE KILLING US.
AND THEY ARE KILLING OUR
DEMOCRACY.
IF I HAVE TO SAY IT OVER AND
OVER EVE